Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week
they finally released the first teaser for
Series 8 so I wanted to do a breakdown of
everything we know about the episodes including
the premiere date. I know in the teaser it
listed August as a general start date but
there's a really good chance they'll show
either the first episode at Comic Con, which
is the last weekend in July. Or they'll
show the first full trailer.
If you're finding me for the first time
I'm doing bonus videos for Doctor Who until
it comes back. Be sure to subscribe to get
everything. When it does come back I'll
be doing weekly episode videos with a giveaway,
Q&As and Bonus videos. Basically the same
thing I'm doing for Game of Thrones right
now.
There's been a history of showing the first
episode at a convention a week in advance
of the world premiere, but doing some reverse
math. If you look at the 50th Anniversary,
they didn't start showing trailers till
about 3 or 4 weeks before the episode. So
it's possible that if they only show the
trailer at Comic Con, the first episode won't
premiere till the end of August.
If you're confused about why they haven't
already told us the exact day Series 8 will
premiere, it's not because they're trying
to be mysterious. It's because they're
not done editing the episodes.
In order to start showing episodes they have
to have enough of them completely finished
so that they can air one a week for the duration
of the series. So right now they're still
shooting the last couple and almost finished
editing the first couple.
I wouldn't be surprised if they were doing
final edits on the last episode after the
first couple have already aired. TV is a little
weird in that production happens on a rolling
basis, so that different episodes are always
in various states of production at any given
time. Unlike a movie which has to be completely
finished before the premiere.
That doesn't even take into account the
Christmas Special. They haven't made a formal
announcement, but there will be 13 episodes
this year. They'll all air this year and
historically series have 12 regular episodes
with 1 Christmas Special. I hope they don't
wait till Comic Con to make the announcement,
but either way we'll know by July if that
13th episode is the Christmas Special.
So the good news is, thanks to people taking
pictures and doing detective work around the
set, we know a lot about what each of the
episodes are going to be this year. Not full
plots, that would be kind of spoilery, but
we do know a lot of general things. So here's
a breakdown of everything we know by order
of episode:
Episodes 1 will be in Victorian London with
the Paternoster Gang. It will basically be
the story that will showcase what this new
regeneration is going to be. It will spell
out his new personality and inform what his
relationship with Clara is going to be like
and set up the big over-arching plot. Remember,
when Matt Smith debuted in series 5, they
used that first episode to set up the Cracks
in the Universe.
There will be a short cameo from Matt Smith.
It only supposed to be the audio from a phone
call that he placed before his regeneration.
That's what all the business with Handles
and the Phone was during the Christmas Special
last year.
Episode 2 - This is also from Ben Wheatley,
he's doing both the first two episodes.
The only teasers we've got are that it's
a Dalek story and The Doctor will be going
"behind enemy lines" and he teased the
word Lasagna. As Daleks do not eat Lasagna
I have no idea what that means, but it's
possible that the Doctor could be going to
Skaro again or he could be visiting a planet
in the middle of a Dalek battle.
If you remember, at the beginning of Series
7 the Doctor traveled to Skaro but it was
just a trick. So Skaro is still in ruins but
it is there. I think it was destroyed before
the end of the Time War. So I don't think
the events of the 50th Anniversary affected
it.
Episode 3 - This is Mark Gatiss' episode
and the rumored title is Robots of Sherwood.
Tom Riley is playing Robin Hood, Ben Miller
is the Sheriff of Nottingham, Trevor Cooper
is Friar Tuck. It's the knights that are
the robots. Jenna Louise Coleman even gets
to shoot a bow Lord of The Rings style.
Episode 4 - The title is rumored to be Listen.
This is Samuel Anderson's first episode.
And the premise is "when you talk to yourself,
what if the person you were talking to isn't
really you?" This just reminds me of Nightmare
in Silver when Mr Clever was trying to take
over The Doctor's Brain and The Doctor was
talking to himself, but technically he was
talking to Mr Clever who was also inside his
mind.
Robert Goodman's character is only listed
as Reg, and the only other Reg I know was
the husband of Madge Arwell from the 2012
Christmas Special. The Doctor, The Widow and
the Wardrobe. Robert Goodman looks way older
than that person, so either he's a totally
different character or he's an older version
of him.
Episode 5 - The rumored title is Time Heist.
It's Keeley Hawes episode where she'll
plays Ms Delphox. She supposedly works at
a bank in the far future, which would explain
the heist theme. But she's also supposed
to have a dark secret. That's just the description.
I know a lot of people are theorizing she
might be the Rani or even a female master.
The funny thing about that is that almost
every single cast member except for Clara
is rumored to be the new Master.
Episode 6 -- We don't know what the title
is, but it's supposed to take place at Coal
Hill School with The Doctor posing as the
Caretaker. We got to see a little bit of the
inside of the School when Clara was finishing
a lesson during the 50th Anniversary Special.
Episode 7 -- The rumored title is Kill the
Moon. And we have seen a few set pictures
of Danny Pink in a spacesuit outside the TARDIS,
so I think we can connect those with this
episode.
I don't want to say there's a plot to
blow up the moon, but a title like Kill the
Moon implies something might get destroyed.
I does also kind of make me think of The Doctor's
Wife with Father being a living organism inhabiting
an asteroid. So maybe there will be something
living inside the Moon that the Doctor will
have to save.
Episode 8 -- The rumored title is Mummy on
the Orient Express.
Then the rumored titled of episode 9 is Flatline
and we don't know anything about episodes
10 through 13 yet.
We get the best info whenever they shoot outdoor
scenes because people are able to take pictures.
We don't know who the writers or directors
are of those last 4 episodes, but Neil Gaiman
is going to try and write another episode
depending on his schedule working out and
Peter Jackson said that talk of him directing
an episode was getting serious.
He had joked about directing an episode last
year, but because of production on The Hobbit
it wasn't taken too seriously. But if anything
changes I'll be sure to post an update.
Steven Moffat hasn't officially announced
what they're doing at Comic Con but there's
usually a tumblr meetup and they're pretty
good about bringing footage. So plan for either
the first full trailer or the first episode.
If they show a big trailer in the next month
I'd say the odds of them showing the whole
episode are pretty good.
Now that we're getting closer to the premiere
I'll start doing more bonus videos, so be
sure to subscribe to get everything and be
sure to leave me suggestions for stuff you
guys want to talk about. Also let me know
if you guys want me to do a Doctor Who Q&A
video this week.
My schedule is kind of crazy right now just
because I'm out of town at a wedding and
I'm already behind on my Game of Thrones
bonus video. But I'll try to get everything
Right now click here to learn about some of
the new characters in series 8 and click here
for the top 10 monsters I think they should
bring back.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!
Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week
they finally released the first teaser for
Series 8 so I wanted to do a breakdown of
everything we know about the episodes including
the premiere date. I know in the teaser it
listed August as a general start date but
there's a really good chance they'll show
either the first episode at Comic Con, which
is the last weekend in July. Or they'll
show the first full trailer.
If you're finding me for the first time
I'm doing bonus videos for Doctor Who until
it comes back. Be sure to subscribe to get
everything. When it does come back I'll
be doing weekly episode videos with a giveaway,
Q&As and Bonus videos. Basically the same
thing I'm doing for Game of Thrones right
now.
There's been a history of showing the first
episode at a convention a week in advance
of the world premiere, but doing some reverse
math. If you look at the 50th Anniversary,
they didn't start showing trailers till
about 3 or 4 weeks before the episode. So
it's possible that if they only show the
trailer at Comic Con, the first episode won't
premiere till the end of August.
If you're confused about why they haven't
already told us the exact day Series 8 will
premiere, it's not because they're trying
to be mysterious. It's because they're
not done editing the episodes.
In order to start showing episodes they have
to have enough of them completely finished
so that they can air one a week for the duration
of the series. So right now they're still
shooting the last couple and almost finished
editing the first couple.
I wouldn't be surprised if they were doing
final edits on the last episode after the
first couple have already aired. TV is a little
weird in that production happens on a rolling
basis, so that different episodes are always
in various states of production at any given
time. Unlike a movie which has to be completely
finished before the premiere.
That doesn't even take into account the
Christmas Special. They haven't made a formal
announcement, but there will be 13 episodes
this year. They'll all air this year and
wait till Comic Con to make the announcement,
but either way we'll know by July if that
13th episode is the Christmas Special.
So the good news is, thanks to people taking
pictures and doing detective work around the
set, we know a lot about what each of the
episodes are going to be this year. Not full
plots, that would be kind of spoilery, but
we do know a lot of general things. So here's
a breakdown of everything we know by order
of episode:
Episodes 1 will be in Victorian London with
the Paternoster Gang. It will basically be
There will be a short cameo from Matt Smith.
It only supposed to be the audio from a phone
The only teasers we've got are that it's
a Dalek story and The Doctor will be going
"behind enemy lines" and he teased the
word Lasagna. As Daleks do not eat Lasagna
I have no idea what that means, but it's
possible that the Doctor could be going to
Skaro again or he could be visiting a planet
in the middle of a Dalek battle.
If you remember, at the beginning of Series
7 the Doctor traveled to Skaro but it was
just a trick. So Skaro is still in ruins but
it is there. I think it was destroyed before
the end of the Time War. So I don't think
the events of the 50th Anniversary affected
it.
Episode 3 - This is Mark Gatiss' episode
and the rumored title is Robots of Sherwood.
Tom Riley is playing Robin Hood, Ben Miller
is the Sheriff of Nottingham, Trevor Cooper
is Friar Tuck. It's the knights that are
the robots. Jenna Louise Coleman even gets
to shoot a bow Lord of The Rings style.
Episode 4 - The title is rumored to be Listen.
This is Samuel Anderson's first episode.
And the premise is "when you talk to yourself,
what if the person you were talking to isn't
really you?" This just reminds me of Nightmare
in Silver when Mr Clever was trying to take
over The Doctor's Brain and The Doctor was
talking to himself, but technically he was
talking to Mr Clever who was also inside his
mind.
Robert Goodman's character is only listed
as Reg, and the only other Reg I know was
the husband of Madge Arwell from the 2012
Christmas Special. The Doctor, The Widow and
the Wardrobe. Robert Goodman looks way older
than that person, so either he's a totally
Episode 5 - The rumored title is Time Heist.
It's Keeley Hawes episode where she'll
plays Ms Delphox. She supposedly works at
a bank in the far future, which would explain
the heist theme. But she's also supposed
to have a dark secret. That's just the description.
I know a lot of people are theorizing she
might be the Rani or even a female master.
The funny thing about that is that almost
every single cast member except for Clara
is rumored to be the new Master.
Episode 6 -- We don't know what the title
is, but it's supposed to take place at Coal
Hill School with The Doctor posing as the
Caretaker. We got to see a little bit of the
inside of the School when Clara was finishing
a lesson during the 50th Anniversary Special.
Episode 7 -- The rumored title is Kill the
Moon. And we have seen a few set pictures
of Danny Pink in a spacesuit outside the TARDIS,
so I think we can connect those with this
I don't want to say there's a plot to
blow up the moon, but a title like Kill the
Moon implies something might get destroyed.
I does also kind of make me think of The Doctor's
living inside the Moon that the Doctor will
have to save.
it wasn't taken too seriously. But if anything
changes I'll be sure to post an update.
in.